Apache es uno de los perros cazadores de
Salvador es un Pointer o perro demuestra
su labor es apuntar Dónde se encuentra
la presa y una vez muerta buscarla y
traérsela al cazador para Salvador su
perro es como su hijo pero siente que
los cazadores están mal vistos por la
sociedad y más ahora que los animales de
caza no están incluidos en la ley de
bienestar animal aprobada en España
nosotros mismos por y para la naturaleza
conservamos la naturaleza conservamos el
monte cuidamos de nuestros animales no
lo abandonamos como se suele decir que
abandona un perro no a un cazador desde
la federación madrileña de caza no
niegan que exista el abandono o el
maltrato en la práctica cinegética Pero
en ningún caso la defienden a nosotros
estaremos siempre en contra Y
denunciaremos ante los tribunales
cualquier maltrato a cualquier animal
sin embargo este maltrato y abandono lo
ve a diario maricarmen Ven aquí de los
300 perros que viven en este albergue el
99% llegó de la mano de cazadores que ya
no los necesitaban
Tenemos un montón de perros sumamente
viejitos que los han traído para no
pagar el sacrificio del animal
claramente bajo la nueva ley el
sacrificio injustificado y el abandono
están penados incluso para los cazadores
los pastores también están exentos de
algunas restricciones que impone la ley
para ellos y sus perros
Álvaro que trabaja con ovejas desde hace
más de 20 años cree que estas leyes
están hechas desde una cosmovisión
urbana que olvida la simbiosis milenaria
entre animales y humanos ellas forman
parte de nuestra civilización también es
que y gracias a ellas y a ellos a los
perros y a los caballos que han
trabajado También tenemos estamos donde
estamos una utilidad a cambio de
protección cuidados y respeto mutuo las
bases de lo que todos ellos consideran
el verdadero bienestar animal